thank you nate the martial arts usa
world championships are happening this
weekend at the west gate as well as the
karate hall of fame
earlier i spoke with paul casey the
event organizer hall of famer dave
hebler who was elvis's personal
bodyguard
and we started off with a future hall of
famer
everybody meet georgie georgie are you
ready
yeah go ahead oh
how's that feel good yes georgie is on
his way to becoming a martial
arts master and this is georgie's father
over here paul
one how proud are you or your son he's
breaking boards and secondly tell us
about the usa championships this weekend
he's amazing he's my inspiration but
you've met him many times in the past
georgie is going to be incredible he's
going to be at the event the whole
weekend which
is the 35th anniversary of the usa
world championships in law in las vegas
with stanwood's it's going to be an
incredible weekend now people can come
down and watch other tournaments taking
place this weekend as well
yeah the tournament is actually all day
tomorrow saturday from
to eight till whenever it closes and
then follows with the awards banquet
which
is at uh 6 30 and then sunday there's
competition as well
all right so you have to get something
set up we're doing something very
special here in just a second and i want
you to meet someone very special
dave hebler who was elvis's personal
security guard you also taught a martial
arts as well
hall of famer himself so dave first off
how did your connection with elvis
how did that happen i met him in a
karate school
we were a group of us got together down
in santa monica at
parker school and were all working out
out on the mats and there was a
commotion at the door
and i looked and walked but my god elvis
presley
and i'm thinking what's he doing here
well he was watching for a while and
then to my
amazement he actually got on the mats
with us and started you know working out
with us
with me as his uh as his dummy his
workout partner
now how did martial arts affect elvis
how did martial arts change elvis
you know what i think it gave him more
focus and more motivation
he loved the martial arts he was a
martial artist his entire adult life by
the way
he had other instructors before i ever
met him
now you're returning to the westgate for
the first time real quick that was the
international back in the day elvis spot
are you excited to be back there
yeah i am it's kind of a bittersweet and
kind of a nostalgic
it's all changed everything is so
different you know i don't even know
where i'm at
yeah you're in las vegas you're ready to
go all right you're going to show me how
to
break a board right all right let's go
come on here we go what is the technique
okay the technique is in the first place
you're going to break with this part of
this
okay and what you want to do is hit the
exact center
and with your left foot forward like
here
and then you're going to lean into it
and then as you break it
you're just going to drop onto it like
that just bend your knee
bam okay here we go it makes it look so
easy george you made it like swissy hold
that there oh here we go
i'm thinking of the montreal canadiens
right now
yeah nope nope nope
nope is this is this a gimmick board is
not working one more time
how much time do i have lance we're over
time
ah georgie take it away here we go we'll
do one time step over here jerky this is
so hard
just like this right here like this
right here right here
oh there it is that's how you do it
that's how the pros do it thank you so
much paul dave thank you so much it's a
pleasure to meet you my friend
thank you i gotta get some ice you guys
good job georgie thank you guys
appreciate it
i need to work i need to uh i need to
georgie has it down little georgie has
it down
you know no we'll we'll practice we'll
start baby steps we'll get you like uh
like a graham cracker and yeah yeah then
we'll move on we'll get you to the
border
i appreciate it the usa world
championships are this weekend at the
west gate where those hall of fame
inductions
they're taking place saturday night in
las vegas now